all right diane
diana where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i was
born and raised in bellingham washington
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents as a kid um
my mom actually gave me up when i was
about three years old so i grew up
in foster care oh really and got adopted
uh
ended up getting adopted at the age of
seven
how would you describe your childhood
i would describe it
i really want to know um
half good half bad
i mean it's i really can't remember my
childhood
so it's i remember a lot of the bad
stuff
you can't but there was some good times
with family
the bad times was in the foster care
what kind of stuff was going on in the
foster care
yeah um
being starved wasn't allowed to eat
drink
milk juice sodas all we were allowed to
eat was like
ramen noodles once a day and
not even we couldn't even have water no
abuse or anything like that
um mental and emotional abuse some
sometimes a faster mom would hit us
maybe
once in a blue moon
and then eventually you went to a family
at seven
yeah eventually they um found a
foster family that
i loved i i still call it i'll call her
to
tell the day i still call her
and i called her mom so that was a good
experience
the last foster home it was the best
because i found my twin sister
so your actual twin sister yeah
and you guys both were put in the foster
system
and lost each other yeah
what kind of teenager were you um
i guess a little uh what is that what
i'm looking for
not a rebel um
outcast no rebellion or something like
something like that um
[Applause]
i didn't like to listen i didn't when i
was told to stay put i didn't want to go
out
i didn't want to stay i just want to go
run around
get high
i didn't i didn't finish high school so
how far did you go as far as i went
i think was the 11th grade 10th or 11th
grade
and after school what'd you do
i started hoeing being a prostitute
in seattle yeah and i was actually the
age of
i think 16 when i started doing that
you're doing that on your own or with a
pen i've done it all my life by myself
i'm against that pimp stuff
tell me about working as a prostitute
working as a prostitute
um it was easy money
um but it was dangerous
it put me in a lot of bad situations
the reason you were doing it was purely
just to make ends meet
yeah and it was really the only way i
know how to survive because i ended up
being homeless
running and the streets and stuff
any better experiences doing that i've
had
quite a few until this day
i still have some bad experiences you
still doing still doing it today
um i don't do it like i used to ever
when i don't have no money and i haven't
eight a couple days or something
i'll go out there and do what i need to
do so i could eat
yeah and you're staying down here on
schedule yes i've been on skid row
in la for since august 20th to 2000.
you're staying in a tent or i was
right now i've been staying
with my boyfriend in an sro
and our drugs are part of your wife yes
they are
which one is yours i'm a crackhead
but also every now and then uh i'll do
crystal
because i'm trying i'm trying to come
off the stuff
yeah crystal's popular way of getting
off crystal i don't even get high off
i've never gotten high off of it but it
does take the crack cravings away
yeah i've heard that a lot and just the
taste of crystal
just makes me sick
but i'll still do it do you have kids
yes i do i have
a 20 year old
his name is marcus anthony
where is he he's in bellingham
washington with
my adopted mom did she raise her
[ __ ] my mom raised them my adopted mom
raised him yeah i didn't were you in his
life at all
um after she took
i had her take him i didn't see him for
a few years and then i went down back
home to see him and
it was another five six seven years
before i saw him again but lately
the last maybe five years i've been
trying to go
back and forth to home to spend more
time with them but
we are too much alike
really yeah i'm just my birth mom and i
i found her after 35 years
i am weird way too much of like i'm just
like her
my son's just like me we've all we're
all addicts
but i need to get myself together so i
can meet my granddaughter
how's your sister doing um
a matter of fact i have not talked to
her in
i've seen her damn what was it it was a
couple years ago i thought it had been
20 years after after the foster kids
foster home we hadn't seen each other in
like 20 years i finally seen her
and now it's been another couple years
and i haven't heard from her yeah was
she involved in drugs as well
i don't think so not when we're in the
foster home
but from that time to now i really don't
know
i just know she has some mental issues
do you feel like you were ever loved as
a as a child
from my adopted mom
yeah my whole doctor family i knew i was
loved
nowadays i really don't know
yeah it's good roads
it's hard to find love i would think
what emotions do you deal with now
huh what emotions do you do with that
what do you mean
i mean do you get anxious depressed
angry i get depressed
a lot
the only reason why i'm using drugs now
is because i ended up relapsing
in 2019
when my husband died
yeah relapsing is
it's like right around the corner as
soon as anything bad happens you don't
like it
it's hard to stay clean when you have a
lot of people in your family
dying
what are you worried about now
losing somebody else in my family losing
my mom
what's your biggest regret ever start
starting on drugs i wish i never started
on it
how's your how were you first introduced
to drugs
oh [ __ ] i don't even remember that far
back
oh there's no i'm tired i'm ready to get
the [ __ ] off of them
not to be 41 years old and i'm tired
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
oh [ __ ] um
i don't know i know i don't know
oh
do you have hope of getting your life
together huh do you think there's a good
chance that you'll get your life
straight and away from drugs i've talked
to my
uncle because the only time i'm able to
get sober and stuff is when i'm
away from skid row i've already talked
to my uncle kevin
to see if i can move in with him
because anytime i've gotten clean he was
my sponsor
you kind of need an environment i would
think yeah being with my uncle because
he's in
sobriety he's got i think 20 27 years or
between 15 and 27 years clean and sober
you know he stays on me about using
drugs and stuff
do you feel like you had different
parents growing up that might have
changed the direction of your life no
they were the best parents
but i mean your biological parents um
i don't know a whole lot i just know
my mama gave me up i don't know who we
don't know who my father is
right but if you had parents that hadn't
given you up or hadn't lost you
to the foster system that may have
changed it
i really don't i don't know i know
i've i've had some mental issues in the
in the past
and that's a lot of some of the reason
why
i've done i think done what i've done
all right diane well thank you so much
for talking with me
you're welcome i wish you the best of
luck thank you
thank you very much
you